coming up with a name for your YouTube
channel can kind of be frustrating I
mean you might even have set up your
YouTube channel and you're thinking
about renaming it and one of the most
important aspects I really believe of
your channel is thinking about a name
that's going to draw the right audience
get attention give clarity about what
your content is about or just be related
to your personal brand so in this video
we're gonna be sharing three quick tips
on how to choose a powerful YouTube name
some of the mistakes we see some
additional resources but this is also
the think marketing show which means we
answer your questions so at the
beginning of the show we give you some
Power Packs value around one topic then
we go into Q&A for the rest of the show
and so if you just want to stick around
for the beginning that's cool or if you
want to dive deep then you could be here
for the rest as well but if we're just
meeting my name is Sean kennel I'm the
founder of think media and this is our
channel think marketing so I hope you're
subscribed this is where we go deep on
branding positioning and some of the
aspects of building a business as well
as marketing your business wrote a book
with my friend Benji Travis called
YouTube secrets and I'm fired up for
this video where we've got a couple
quick tips for you so let me know um
what your youtube name is and the only
way you have to do that is just drop a
comment on this video because I love
being able to see the comment I'll see
your name but maybe let me know if
you're thinking about changing your name
and tip number one here's the easiest
way to name your channel is just your
first and last name right I think about
some people if you've ever heard of the
personal development coach of course you
probably have Tony Robbins Tony Robbins
you know one of my friends chalene
johnson right maybe you've heard of Gary
Vaynerchuk that he runs vaynermedia and
he wrote some books on social media Gary
Vaynerchuk is what his channel is called
right it's just your first and your last
name right that actually is a good way
to brand your channel now some people
are not comfortable with sharing their
last names and we'll share some
strategies for that but it's a great way
to build a personal brand I actually
have a Sean Cannell channel but I'm not
doing a ton with it's just my first my
last name and someday when I may be
building out my channel more about
high-performance business development I
got
enough to do right now with think media
and think marketing but you're first in
your last name now secondly you could do
your name as well as a brand and this is
an opportunity to potentially not have
to share your last name or you can share
your name last name if you want to and
so here's an example of that McCann dogs
that's actually their last name right
and it's a dog channel where they do
training and how to train your dogs and
whatnot and so there's last name plus a
brand promise and this is really strong
because you have McCann dog training
they're actually a member of some of our
programs that's a great example of doing
that this is Cass Thompson she was on
the think marketing show she's a VR a
member inner circle member she has cast
Thompson an abbreviation of her first
name she does share a last name and then
career advice a power tip here is if you
can include what your brand does like
the category is your are you doing
career advice are you doing fitness or
are you doing yoga are you doing
you know something specific if you can
actually include that category or if you
include something that even gives more
detail because she goes career and then
obviously advise you not only know it's
about her but you also know kind of the
brand that it's in this is plants and
Lucia right so she has her name Lucia
and then we know what the channel is all
about it's all about plants and it's
been so encouraging to see man when she
actually joined our video ranking
Academy program at like zero or like a
hundred subscribers or something she
just hit 6,000 you also have like Kowboy
Kent Rowland's this is kind of a hybrid
between one and two
you know Kent Rowland's first and last
name but then cowboy obviously with the
brand and it's a cowboy cooking channel
and another opportunity that you have to
do here is again combining like an
actual brand name keywords' as well as
your first and last name era quarry
network marketing pro his brand name
network marketing Pro his event and then
his first and last name so let me
no if either of those two strategies
helped and hit the like button but the
last option is to just go all-in with a
brand name that's what we're doing here
on think marketing and think is the
brand we got to think you know and
mainly because we want you to think
different we want you to think bigger
we want you to you know be thinking
outside of the box and then what are we
talking about marketing the key word
online marketing come on YouTube
marketing helping you and that's what
this channel is all about think media
that's a brand name and media is sort of
kind of a overarching category of online
media producing content producing those
types of things and so you see the tips
kind of summarized you could do your
first and last name number one number
two you can do a name and your brand
name it could just be your first name if
you want to keep your last name private
or your first name last name and brand
name Cass Thompson career advice and
then number three you could do your
brand name completely a couple other
examples of that would be like simply
soccer really strong you know brand name
and you know exactly what the channel is
about again if you can actually include
the promise of the channel in the name
now of course you can do a name think
about like Google you know what does
Google mean well we know it's a search
engine but it didn't mean anything until
meaning was assigned to it and if you
want to come up with some cool name like
maybe you're in gaming and your name is
like fire ice two to five like maybe it
doesn't mean anything but eventually
you're like beating everybody and now
your name you know means something else
you could come up with something cool
but practically this has been it's one
of our VRA members Kido camp is a really
strong name on his cover
Kito camp with Ben Azadi right so you've
got the it's about ketogenic s-- camp
spelled creatively right with camp with
the K kind of stands out plant-based
kitchen with Cammie now this is actually
Tony on the think media team and he does
a lot of stuff and video ranking Academy
and we actually are doing a YouTube
influencer challenge he's going to be in
tradin this is his wife in a channel
that they kind of do together and it's
her channel and they're just getting
started but again the promise is in the
title so a really good YouTube channel
name brand name the plant-based kitchen
and you kind of know what you're gonna
get it's plant-based content right
here's live BAE lash they're some
business owners they shared they were at
our event growth video live this last
year and so live Bay is kind of the
brand name and then lashes because their
lash artist they do you know different
lash they have a they sell the products
they actually train lash artists they've
got brick-and-mortar lash businesses so
just a lot of different opportunities
that you can have so again you can go
first to last name you can do something
with just your first name and if it's
only your first name you've got to be
weird to name your channel Sean like SCA
n maybe like your first name plus
whatever the brand is and then number
three of course just a brand name period
and if you haven't left a comment yet
drop a comment so we can see your name
and let us know if that helps in if
you're thinking about changing it hit
the like button if you're getting value
and I'm excited for the show today
because of course we have Heather and
Mel coming on but if you haven't
registered yet this show is brought to
you by the YouTube influencer challenge
and we're so excited about this
challenge that's coming up you can get
in for free at tube influence comm link
in the description below starting soon
we're gonna be doing a 7-day challenge
what's that means everyday we're going
live for an hour actually we have about
a set we have a session in the morning a
session at night it is this is content
that normally is only existing inside of
some of our paid coaching programs but
we're given away for free as like a
stimulus during this crazy time in the
world to help you get momentum on your
channel and so definitely get signed up
it's gonna be amazing if you're an
influencer if you're an author speaker
coach or online marketer you definitely
want to be a part if you're an
entrepreneur business owner you're gonna
love this or if you're a creator whether
you're just starting youtube or even if
you're more advanced you're gonna love
this content and so tube influencer calm
to get into that and link in the
description below on youtube or if
you're watching on another channel just
type that URL and makes
you get into the private group because
we're gonna be starting soon and it's
gonna be amazing but I want to bring on
Heather and Mel to the show today how's
it going guys it's going great I mean
we've been live everywhere today so it's
been a really great day and I love
talking about channel names because that
is the you know the the the beginning of
starting something new so I love this
topic how about you Mel yeah I
completely agree I think channel names
is a question that we get so frequently
how do i name my channel and its really
impactful to the rest of your strategy
and I think that just the simple act of
like thinking through your channel name
sparks a lot of other really important
questions so I'm also very excited for
this topic absolutely and so I want to
hear from Heather in a second because
she has kind of a double name going on
her channel but if you've got a question
we're now entering into the Q&A portion
of the show the best way for us to see
that wherever you're watching is to
throw up for question marks before and
after your question Mel's gonna grab
those and we'd love to help you with
whatever when it comes to social media
online business pivoting your plan or
anything to do with YouTube but Heather
your channel is your first and last name
but you also have a brand name what kind
of processes have you gone through in
trying to pick out your channel name
yeah for me um I really wanted it to be
known in two ways I wanted to be known
as a brand name and because there's so
many Heather's in the world I wanted my
name to stand out even Heather Torres is
a very popular name and so I wanted the
ability that if someone typed my name in
a Google search bar maybe they heard me
on a podcast or they saw me speak on
stage or someone's friend told them that
I do homeschooling and they're like it's
Heather Torres just just type that in I
wanted my content to come up and because
I'm so passionate about homeschooling I
wanted to make sure that I also had that
in my name so my channel name is Heather
Torres but my channel topic is the
home-school house so we're talking all
about learning through life together
this is a homeschooling and motherhood
channel and it's
for new home school moms and I really
wanted to make sure that I was making
content that they could literally type
in the search bar homeschooling Heather
or Heather homeschool understanding how
people type things in was really
important to me in understanding how I
wanted that to look in let's be real it
didn't start like this I didn't just
have this epiphany in this clarity at
first I think I named it like just
Heather and homeschooling and then I
changed it to the home school house and
then I was like I probably should have
my name in there and so I changed it
again and here's the thing I think
marketing you can change your name it's
okay it's about the content that you're
creating I stuck with the same topic so
I knew I was talking about homeschooling
and I just changed it as I developed as
a creator so if you're just starting
right now and you're like I can't make
that decision and that's what's holding
you back my challenge to you tonight is
to just come up with the name put it in
that YouTube in that YouTube space and
get started because the name can always
evolve what does Google even mean they
just chose a name and then they started
creating a business around it that's
what we want you to do here I'm going to
just choose a name and move forward and
I get it there's privacy things why
people don't want to use their first and
last name but if you know that you want
to make an impact in people's lives I
recommend that you go first and last
because you want to be known for your
first and last name and the more you
have your first and last name being said
the more your influence will grow so
that was how I decided to do it Shawn I
know you also have another channel Shawn
talk about that yeah you know I want to
just mention this resource too if you
want to check out this video it's linked
in the description below link it on the
YouTube card and this there's a couple
tools so we're not gonna go into a into
them in this because we want to answer
your questions
but there's a couple other things you
want to think about when it comes to
picking a name may be that there's tools
like bust a name where it'll help you
think of a thoughts thesaurus like if
you want to think about a Power word to
include your first name a power word a
brand name if you're trying to get
creative so definitely check out that
video and some of the other things to
consider Heather are you know this a
little more advanced but think even
bigger than your YouTube
like what brand do you want to build
there's a website called name check com
so you could think about is your name
available across social media or is
there competition because we would
recommend here and think marketing you
got to think bigger than just your
YouTube channel what's the bigger
business what's the bigger brand now
maybe your YouTube channel is just a
project but do you want the social media
accounts for everything and will that
translate across all the platforms kind
of a lot to think about so definitely
check out that bonus video but Melissa
I'm excited to jump into our first
question smash like think marketing if
you're getting value and Mel what are we
talking about today
yeah brother Bruce has a great question
is it better to keep names short or is
it better for them to be descriptive mmm
really good question you know this is a
big challenge
short is good because short can maybe be
it's obviously easier to type it's may
be easier to fit if if it's too long it
has to go in multiple lines or if it
gets cut off maybe they can't see the
whole thing brings us to a few other
tips that include things like how easy
to spell is it you know how easy to
pronounce is it and sometimes these can
be challenges we think about URLs like
kennel is messed up people call me
Cannell all the time so I started saying
Shawn kennel rhymes with YouTube channel
if I told you to go to Shawn kennel com
on a podcast yeah you gonna type that in
I have to spell it out that's a tip if
you're marketing yourself branding
yourself I'll go SCA n like Sean puffy
combs come on I'm a hip-hop art and then
I'll be like CA and an elo you got to
spell it out so I think there's
definitely some aspects to consider when
it comes to how long it should be I
think shorter if possible but
descriptive is very important and
thinking about the words you use and
there's a lot that goes into it but I
don't know how they're what would you
say yeah I'm more for the short and
punchy only because when you want to be
known especially when you're just
getting started having something super
long so it being like Heather Torres
photography channel or motherhood
photography or newborn photography want
to just remember the thing the one thing
the thing you're known for so I think
media we're too
about media and unthink marketing we're
talking about marketing so we just like
to keep it small that is a personal
preference but like I said I want it to
be something that people can remember
that's the biggest thing when it comes
to coming up with your brand name is
just can people remember it so that's
what my tip would be there's also power
tips like rhyming like my friend
Charlie's got a channel called charisma
on command and it has like that's the
two c's and it kind of flows so I love
what Heather said don't get stuck at
some point eventually got a pick a name
press record you got to go for it I'll
be honest there was a lot of reasons and
I think we launched this channel in this
podcast that thick marketing podcasts at
the perfect time but I I debated Heather
will tell you and Mel I probably go for
over a year I was like do we call it
think marketing I don't know is that too
short doesn't need another word I mean
I'm we're with you
we stress out just as much or more as
you do at some point done is better than
perfect come up with something strong
check out that other video because it'll
give you a few other tools and resources
and then pick a name and go forward and
press record so Shawn Fannie Beth wants
to know it does Google limit how often
you can change your name that's a great
question I am unsure in terms of your
YouTube channel name to be clear there's
a couple opportunities you have when it
comes to YouTube one is the fact that
you can do YouTube you have your URL
don't worry about your URL too much we
have youtube.com for its last think
marketing okay now you can pretty much
change that one time and once you hit a
certain number of subscribers you can
get a custom URL don't worry about it I
know huge youtubers whose name like I
think about my friend Jefferson Bethke
in his channels his first and last name
and his his URL is like bball 26 you
know what I mean like it's just like
completely unrelated
heather's is like hick taurus yeah it's
my kids it's mine and my kids it was
when I had one child so it was my
husband myself my one child last name
nothing to do with what it's doing now
but it's just the link and I still use
it so that is yours
Oh URL right but then you also have your
actual name this is what matters and you
can change this I'm sorry I actually
don't know the answer you can change it
multiple times here's the best advice
you don't want to change it that often
like I would I wouldn't recommend I
wouldn't recommend changing it barely at
all I think you could change it maybe
it's been one way for three months and
you want to pivot maybe you're gonna
take your channel in a new direction you
want to change it
I'll admit that for the longest time
think media was actually called think
space media space capital TV and I
tripped out about that I was like let's
slim it down let's get it clearer
in fact even on the video that we were
just looking at in the intro it was
think media TV in the opening branding
and so that was a pretty easy pivot but
I just deleted the TV right and actually
the URL still has the TV so you know
this stuff's not necessarily clean and
perfect you don't want to change it a
lot but is it okay to pivot your channel
absolutely and I would eventually stick
with something in build build build this
is a great follow-up question to the
channel name links question and it's if
shorter is better than is it better to
just use the real estate within the name
to describe your channel as opposed to
putting you know having your full name
in it or something yeah I think plants
and Lucia is strong it's plants and a
first name and it's short it's punchy
and it's clear I think again I don't if
your name even becomes a little bit
longer like Shawn photography tips with
Shawn that's not super long but it's got
the tips it's got the keyword
photography those are a couple the
elements you really want to include I
think having it be search based for
YouTube but keep in mind you're really
gonna get discovered because of your
specific videos not because of your
channel your videos are the pathways the
gateway into your world and so your
brand name also I think can suffer if
it's too specific think media is
actually kind of an opportunity for us
because the videos have conditioned the
community to what we're known for
probably more than anything best camera
for YouTube or how to make a youtube
video but think media is broad enough as
a brand name that it can volved it can
evolve and grow into something else by
the way you may have noticed that we are
kind of simplifying the brand of our
whole company to just think you know
think media think marketing we have our
think media mastermind we have our think
tank which is a one-day coaching program
with me with a small group of 20 people
or less and and so think is kind of what
we rallying around and and my friends
this may maybe appears like it's been
architected and it certainly has we
think long and hard about these things
but we also I feel like we've stumbled
here by God's grace and serendipity cuz
I'm like yeah this thing turned out
pretty cool let's pick this out of a hat
ten years ago because we had another
project called think international and I
wanted to do the media side of it so
we're always staring pivoting trying to
play the hand you're dealt always
debating about like is it available on
social and you know what we don't really
have think media social media accounts
we have sean kennel social media
accounts if your name is Dave Smith I'm
sorry you're probably not gonna be able
to get that on social media luckily I
got my first and last name clean across
social media there wasn't a lot of other
people with my isle of man Gaelic Irish
last name and so that's just a couple
thoughts there but yeah all right I was
hoping we could rapid-fire through a
couple specific questions on people's
names so in spoke place is wondering if
they should leave their name is in slow
place when their niche is minimalism and
mindfulness smallness inspo place
mmm-hmm yeah I mean it sounds like a
brand to me it's what you make of it so
oh I love how clean it is like here's
what I see right when we go to this
channel Sean I see clean and minimalism
what do you see
yeah absolutely I think that again the
way you're gonna get known
for minimalism is these titles mindful
minimalism people coming you know I
think about to my friends benji and judy
Travis
Judy's original channels it's Judy time
and eventually like it just sticks with
me and its beauty time with its Judy
time I don't even know if she loves that
name anymore
he called his channel Benji man TV cuz
he thought I'd be a man channel and TV
maybe cuz I called my think media TV
like who even has a TV anymore now it's
like screens and Mark whatever and so
that all that is - is encourage you that
your videos are gonna build your brand
that for better or worse it might stick
for you and I we think this name is
great but it you'll become in smoke
device like oh yeah in SPO place one of
my favorite channels all about
mindfulness and so I think it's great
what does mal think I agree with
everything for one I really like your
hair into a place it is magnificent so I
would subscribe just for that I just
like your general look but I do think
what Sean is saying is that you know
generally speaking the titles and the
overall look of your page is more
impactful to me than the actual title so
I would say if you like it go for it
alright you ready for the next one yeah
yeah um amine codes asking their channel
is called the crafter encoder because
they do crafting and coding encoding Mel
send me the link and I want to answer a
question too because we are multi
streaming shout out if you're curious
about how we're streaming think media
tools is where you can always find the
tools that we use this is stream yard
and we love it because it's so easy to
pop up and switch around that's how
we're doing all the switching and the
screen sharing it's all web-based so we
love live streaming with this you might
be watching this over on Facebook and
someone was like hey I want to think
media I couldn't see it I know we got a
lot going on so this is our new thick
marketing channel and if you haven't
checked it out and subscribed yet then
definitely head to youtube and also
check us out on the podcast like we have
a podcast I don't know if you are
driving you might not be driving much
right now during the lockdown or if
you've got a commute or you like to work
out or jump on the treadmill or anything
like that and listen to podcasts we have
a weekly show it comes out every single
Tuesday and that's an awesome chance to
check out the think marketing podcast
we're just getting going it's been a fun
journey and so check that as well and so
this is the YouTube channel where this
is streaming Mel let's check out that
channel all right I dropped you a link
in our doc if you got it
and in our chat all right
crafter and coder I'll tell you my
initial impressions is that at least
initially I don't
I think of crafting maybe not even
different than what you mean learn to
code craft and the see and see the world
from a new perspective so when I think
about craft are you thinking about
crafting code or like DIY modge podge
like this potentially and code I think
it's pretty unique but it's two things
that I would normally never see together
and what I wonder this is pretty awesome
sword though you're making here is is
that it it kind of is a sticking point
for me in my mind Heather what do you
think yeah when I saw crafter I
immediately thought what you were doing
crafting and coding while I think those
are two really great niches to be in I'm
not seeing a meld together as much so I
would pick one which one do you love to
make content about do you want to be in
this coding space do you want to help
people learn how to code and share the
things you know or do you want to be and
more of the DIY crafting space to me
those are actually two separate things
versus a channel like a channel like
Sean what is the nerd Fitness it's like
Fitness and and like they dress up as
superheroes and they do Fitness that to
me is when you meld
two things together but I really want to
encourage you pick one and then go deep
in
that one yeah this actually brings up a
good point to think marketing we want to
help you win right and what can happen
is sometimes it takes discipline to do
that sometimes it takes discipline to
actually pick a path so that you have
clarity in your brand clarity in your
message your content starts to make
sense
look it's YouTube is a place where you
can do whatever you want you literally
could have the channel where you go this
is all me man
I am a you know I play Dungeons &
Dragons and I listen to vinyl music and
as I post those videos and then I read
story books and I have five different
shows on five different days of the week
most of the time those channels really
struggle whereas if you get really
specific and you become on all like
vinyl music music review newest song cut
like when you get really Specht specific
and pick one niche then a lot of times I
can lead to growth if you want to
potentially keep multiple things going
you just might do that at the sacrifice
of confusing the audience and this is
think marketing here's a marketing
principle pillar that we teach on this
channel if you confuse you lose clarity
is power if you confuse you lose look on
the Internet
you got to make you have to you want to
be clear quick people are trying to
decide is this right for me or not and I
think coding is super strong so is
crafting but I think if you know coding
people want to learn coding people want
coding tutorials they want to learn
specific searchable things in coding so
there's something powerful that could
happen I think if you pick one greed all
right propel soccer or propel Soccer
Academy and don't have a link for them
but if I would actually go with propel
soccer because to me that's the wider
brand propel Soccer Academy sounds like
a product to me so I wouldn't name my
channel on a product unless you actually
are doing a product like if I was like
coffee cups that would be a product and
I would make a channel all around coffee
cups but I would think the Academy
actually is the product that you could
sell later on but having it as the
overarching brand could allow for merch
it could offer products it could allow
for
coaching it could allow for events I
mean it really allows for it to be a
larger larger brand name and I think
it's a really clear one I'm like I know
what it's about so that to me is very
striking exactly right and our Academy
happens to be called video ranking
Academy for this specific promise of
helping you get views 24/7 and rank your
videos in search and suggested but we
certainly could create like a think
media Academy where maybe we teach all
things that it's maybe about how to
shoot on your camera and yet think media
same idea and Heather's I think spot-on
you get a bigger brand to play inside
and to be known for and then you can
almost have that extra name that
specific products or maybe a specific
social media channel or even like like a
private group it could be a private
Facebook group you're like hey join me
over here in this specific place where
we go deeper inside of that brand name
it spear is a blogging channel and they
want to know is that a great name you
know I think when it comes to vlogging
you know it's like my friend it's Judi
time in a way she does not make up but
in that title she doesn't have anything
specific in that title but her videos
led to her success and then the name
started to make sense in fact that she
started with beauty and then eventually
did vlogging later it's Judy's life
makes more sense because it's a vlog
channel about her and Benji's life so I
think it's peer is not in my opinion
it's not strong nor weak it's just the
name and you have the opportunity like
Google to make it mean something I do
yeah that's what I'd say okay what about
Zack McCarty versus Zack McCarty real
estate ooh
well go Heather Zack McCarty real estate
right Shawn what are your voting what do
you 100% yes your name or Zack McCarty
realist see I'm like I know what your
channel is about I know who you are I
know what you do go with that one I
think that one's gonna be a really fire
one and Zack McCarty maybe it's just
real estate
right now and then later on you grow
into coaching and you grow into books
you grow and all that but you need to be
known for one thing first before you
start to get bigger than that so having
real estate on there
right away I knew exactly what the
channel is about yeah I agree and I also
think that as a real estate agent I
would want to brand both things together
I would want people to know me know Zach
you know know that I'm this particular
thing and and the truth is although once
you build up a subscriber base you
usually don't want to pivot that
subscriber base into a radically
different direction
you really could change it later you
could almost you could delete the raela
start part and let's say later you it
was like Zach McCarty investing
leadership and business growth and your
audience could evolve with you and into
like or like Zak Bacardi investing and
like that's that same idea like maybe
you should pivot it into real estate
investing the whole time though you're
getting known for your first and last
name I love what Heather said if you're
thinking about the long time I know I
heard of I saw a few people you're like
sure my name online but at some point
we're living in a transparent world
personal brands matter your personal
brand your digital presence especially
during the lockdown man this is like it
matters more than ever before like if
you're not on social if you're not
branding yourself if you're not known
for your first and last name if you're
not top of mind if you're not thinking
about monikers to say like Sean kennel
rhymes with YouTube channel so that you
can be on people so if people go who is
that one person I forget oh I don't know
I don't know what their website is well
that's not gonna help you get business
so you want to be thinking about ways to
make your name sticky make your name you
know become known you want to be known I
knew that I started to have a little bit
of success in my brand when I had it
people start calling me the YouTube guy
I went on a snowboard trip with some
entrepreneurs and they said hey mr.
YouTube come over here and I was like
that's it Gus good when they're
associating that with my name just as
Heather said being known for a thing but
man if you can really you want your
first to name to get out there you know
your first name is your value it's your
brand on LinkedIn people want to hire
you you want to be like oh I'm top a
night
but mine known for that Heather Taurus
home school house whom I go into for
information on home schooling Heather
Taurus she's the queen she's the og in
the new G she's the bomb.com and so
thinking about what your name is
associated with yeah and I actually have
a case study about that I don't know if
you guys have followed um Katherine from
the content bug you know Katherine has
been on YouTube she started as a blogger
in the car as known as the content bug
she created some products around that
and then she started a YouTube channel
talking all about um
now she talks about YouTube tips and
she's a creator and she decided when she
got to a hundred thousand subscribers
she decided to change her name back to
dirt actually - her real name her her
given name because she wants to build a
brand beyond just the content bug so
here's the thing if you're sitting at a
hundred subscribers right now and you're
like oh my goodness I can't change my
name Katherine changed to add a hundred
thousand subscribers she changed
everything in her brand to her name
because she wants to be known in the
industry for someone who gives value and
she wants her name to come up not her
brand to come up so just to give you
that as an example you really want to be
thinking what does this look like long
term and I understand privacy issues I
understand maybe not wanting to give
your kids names out and those type of
things but in the world we're living in
like Sean said there is so much noise
that you want to break through that
noise by having your name being
associated with something
yeah and I'm so excited because
Katherine's actually gonna be coming to
grow with video live our conference that
happens annually if you haven't heard
about it yet growth video live calm and
super pumped that she's gonna be here
and I think that's encouraging I mean
it'll mess with you to keep you up at
night to be thinking about man I've been
known for this for so long I mean I
tripped out about deleting TV off
thanked media and I read people's
comments and they're like what happened
to the TV and you know there's only like
two people but it's even still I was
like I was like oh shoot did I do the
wrong thing is this gonna it's the whole
world gonna melt is it gonna stop
rotating and I know this stuff is hard
but but you can pivot
you can change and yeah if you want to
learn more about growth video live grow
with video live.com so pumped that
catherine and so many other great
speakers and the think media team
including Mel and Heather are gonna be
there also okay
truly rapid-fire for a couple more names
and then we'll get to some more general
questions again but kun farmhouse
cottage they talk about farmhouse and
homesteading yeah good to me
great approved TNA treasures they sell
vintage items yes that sounds the TNA i
would wonder what that means but other
than that treasures to me goes right to
vintage if that's what the channels
around mmm-hmm treasures again to me
also associates with with vintage so
that one's good mms life mastery they
talk about mastering life with multiple
sclerosis yes yeah i was gonna say
what's the MS but it's the disease and
that's good for search term based
mmm-hmm
alright some general questions leader
different influence they picked their
name because it's the name of their book
that i gave you yes and i think that
that is a good foundational name i think
it's fine as it as is i think you could
that's a name that could have with first
and last name like leadership and
influence with sean kennel and it's
maybe the it really clear on what topics
are speaking about but either way really
strong okay what if somebody else has
your same name on youtube ooh that's
really that's a great question you know
a couple things one we don't even want
to go down the rabbit trail of like
copywriting and whatnot you know if it's
your first and last name if I make a
Sean kennel channel if another born John
kennel wants to make the same channel
that's gonna be fine I'll tell you this
even think marketing there was like
seven or eight of them and they were
just nothing they were just not
subscribed no nobody there whatever so
we did our due diligence and we did our
research
they were abandoned they were old and we
looked around the internet and there was
nobody there plus we were leveraging it
off already the fact that we had think
so there's that fact there are multiple
channels that do have potentially the
same name but I would be cautious you
got that's one of the tips in the other
video and if you're just joining this
video I definitely recommend add it to
your watch list there's a link in the
description here on thick marketing on
YouTube to a name checker which it's not
spelled that's not how it's spelled I
forget it's like a there's a dollars are
missing there's a website that will
actually search a name across all social
media in all different places and even
on YouTube you want to do your due
diligence because maybe you're gonna go
up against Goliath inka life's way too
big and you want to pivot so that you're
like you know I've had friends who've
had to change their name I remember one
that was like you know I wanted to have
this certain name but there's a big porn
star that has that exact same name and
she's got a YouTube channel with like
just some kind of content on there and
so I got to go different direction
because like I am constantly associated
across promoted so you got to go look
around and see what's showing up for you
know the content that is potentially
related to your name yeah and even um
for Instagram like like I said my name
Heather Torres is very very common and
so my Instagram handle is different my
all of my name's on social are a little
bit different because I couldn't get my
name miss Heather Torres is what I am
right now so I put Mrs in front of my
name so that I was able to still have as
someone typed in Heather Torres my
picture comes up they could still have
some identifying but that is different
than my youtube name so I just want you
to know that there's grace in this and
that it doesn't necessarily have to be
exactly the same oh there's my cute
puppy yeah Tobi distracted by the
instant feed hey everybody gotta follow
miss Heather Taurus over on Instagram
and this episode's brought to you by the
YouTube influencer seven-day challenge
tube influencer calm you could sign up
for free we're starting soon and there's
Heather and Mel oh look look at how
they're sitting there oh wow what what a
cool
stock photo oh she's holding g7x oh
what's that's happening what were you
guys actually doing on the laptop there
nothing I don't think it was stock
photos and the photos that we take at
that media I was super early in the
morning too cuz it was really hot out
and remember we had to get up super
early to go through that shoe it was fun
yeah I guess summer's here we're already
hit like 90 today eventually we hit like
100 105 so we'll try to go do photo
shoots at like 7:00 it's still like 93
and like wait may see like get out
really quick and like yeah it's just
crazy so fun times mm-hmm alright how
important is your channel banner to
branding hmm good question you know I
think and have even taught in the past
that I think that actually people put a
little too much weight into it so here's
to ask to you here's to thoughts it
matters you should do a good job with it
you should think it through however I
see that a lot of my friends and a lot
of people that give YouTube advice and
I've been guilty of this in the past
spend a lot of time saying you know
really overthinking about the YouTube
banner and here's what here is one
challenge with that it really kind of
matters on desktop because desktop is
when you get the full experience we kind
of barely see it in mobile and you're
not gonna see little words and little
details in mobile so I think that you
should do a good job but you shouldn't
worry about it
for example this channel is done pretty
well and all it is is a picture of us
like you know we say tell how many times
you upload a week explain exactly what
your value proposition is okay or you
know I don't know our about page is not
even done and so like there's nothing
and you can still grow your channel now
conversely these details do matter but
here's the bigger point I'm trying to
make the bigger point is your videos
themself posting videos good content a
breakout video when a video breaks out
on YouTube that is what you'll become
known for you want people to know what
you're all about post a video that gets
views and people go oh yeah you're the
guy who like talks about best
saying that I think best practices are
to try to include your value proposition
and if possible visuals for at your
channel is about again this channel
cameras team lighting YouTube think
media weekly tips and tools for building
your influence online weekly is generic
enough to say was it Monday - I don't
even know it's just for sure it's
happening every week I think you're
gonna get videos every single week now
are like six days a week and in the past
we're like one a week it's weekly
regardless um I do think that for those
who make it to your about page this
one's pretty well written you know
thanks for checking out thick media my
name's Sean kennel I'm the mildly
eccentric and overly caffeinated author
of the number one best-selling book
YouTube secrets caffeine talking right
there so think about your about page I
think one of the myth or tunity these
are these links like you got to be using
your links I give you I see dead links
here that's a mistake I see no links
here that's a huge mistake I see
unnecessary links here like don't also
link everything only link active stuff
I'm active on Instagram I'm active on
Twitter you know we have a link to our
free youtube checklist that if you
haven't got that you could grab that and
so taking advantage of that so I think
the summary is this what is really gonna
change your youtube channel grow your
influence get you known on YouTube
videos that is that'll be the game
changer this branding matter yes does
your name matter yes does your channel
cover matter yes sure but there's been
plenty of channels that are broken out
and it wasn't because of their channel
covered let's just put order of
priorities it was because of video broke
out suspend your best energy thinking
about your next video they get about and
and potentially start with something and
let it evolve over time any thoughts on
that before we go to the next question
Heather yeah I mean if you went to my
channel you would see that it's really
just words I just chose the color I went
to canva.com I made a free youtube
banner I just used the template that
they had I put in the words and then
even learning through life together now
that I'm looking at it is pretty thin I
probably should make that a thicker text
but no we're
read about it it's it is what it is
right now and I would love if my channel
header matched my videos my thumbnails
but it doesn't yet it's okay I'm still
in process you know I uploaded one video
in the last month and so this is a side
project for me and this is probably what
YouTube is for you you're probably
trying to work on YouTube as your side
hustle so little by little I advanced
this channel little by little you know
when you look at think media right now
Sean's been working on think media for
years and so it is developed over time
there's been little tweaks there's been
inspirations you know sometimes Mel and
I will wake up in the morning and Shawn
a bit Hey look what I did and you know
he had some extra time and decided to
change the channel banner or update the
about page it all is just one thing at a
time so if you're feeling overwhelmed
and you're thinking how am I gonna get
all this done just choose one thing a
week that you're gonna work on and then
like Sean said put the energy and time
into actually creating the videos hey
ready for some more rapid-fire I'm ready
hit like if you're getting value out of
this video here on Facebook smash like
share it with somebody if you're on
YouTube hit the like button thanks for
being here resources in the show notes
below if you haven't registered for the
tube influence comm challenge what are
you thinking come on we are gonna be
going live every day for seven days
sharing some of our best information
that is previously only been available
in our coaching program I mean I saw
Debra saying what is the best place to
start you know learning about n screens
and screens the YouTube challenge I mean
we're gonna be in here answering your
questions sharing content every day you
know previously this information is
available in our $2,000 coaching program
but this is a crazy time in the world
and we believe it's never been a better
time to build your influence on YouTube
so we are doing this challenge all the
details are at tube influence comm and
what you do is you just jump in and
it'll walk you through the steps of how
you can get involved and get all the
information and so I check it out the 7
day free live YouTube influencer
challenge with the think media team
including Tony Arriola Mel Caputo
Heather Taurus Nolan malt Omar el Tacori
many guests from our community it's
gonna be amazing
okay next question now I was an amazing
voiceover right there Sean thank you for
that that was exactly what I needed for
the ads but we need for this thank you
alright our rapid fire our little
sparrows it's a channel for pregnancy
and invest infant loss support oh yes I
think that's great
Chandler's pen a writing channel makes
sense to me mm-hmm Hope through prophecy
channel about bible messages you guys
ended in a hopeful way mm-hmm makes
sense
alright cym now celebrating your moments
now they're a wedding company mm-hmm I
believe their channel name is CY em now
I'm not sure if the celebrating your
moments now it's on it spelled out yeah
in isolation it is a little tough once
explained it makes sense and so it's
kind of like the idea of think about it
like this
a book title and a book subtitle so if
it was you know maybe you already have
that LLC and that's like your company
name great cym now semicolon you know
wedding event planning and like and then
describing what it is and then and then
again people eventually go oh they're
the best
oh you haven't worked with them at cym
now they're amazing they do wedding but
and eventually again the name carries
weight once you've delivered services
but it is nice to potentially I think
add that descriptor of exactly what
people can expect on the channel all
right what about back to basics dog
training or dog training by Leon ooh
so choosing between yeah I'm gonna say
both they're really good dog training by
Leon that adds your name so that it
separates you out a little bit more than
back to basics back to basics actually
sounds like a product to me now that I
know that the other option is dog
training with Leon makes sense what do
you think Sean yeah I agree I also think
in
I'm not trying to get done is better
than perfect friends but you want you
want some advance thinking about this is
your business built to sell there's a
book called built to sell and you can of
course pivot names later but think about
your vision and so you know if you're
like I kinda want to have a home-based
personal based business forever you know
or like a local based with like Leon and
the name but they're all there is
something about the fact I even think
about this from you know I thought about
think media which we don't intend to
sell a thick media really ever but I was
like oh it's not my name like it can
scale think about this I think media can
scale bigger than me it is already look
at other here's Heather here's Mel
here's what there's all kinds of people
here now I was to shoot videos I'm up
literally in my small town I'm a college
dropout shooting videos in my bedroom
and I was like think media and I'm just
this kid shooting videos and now we're
like this company with like brands and
all this other stuff life's got real
weird but it wasn't being built up on
like Sean's YouTube tips calm or
whatever that's actually a separate
channel is just my personal channel I
don't need you to think that deep about
it really but like there you might want
to and I think on think marketing we
really talk about business here there is
something about what are you building
what could it turn into and one other
thought is a lot for Leon Mel said
rapid-fire but you know the other
thought is sometimes you maybe have a
list of cool names if you're an
entrepreneur and a creative like us you
probably have all kinds of names and you
want to start new projects and new
things sometimes you're like oh I want
to start another YouTube channel I'll be
like a great channel name what we've
learned is that we get to use a lot of
different names on different projects
that are related to our brand we got so
many different brands now grow with
video live is our is our event that
would be a good channel name can't take
it out cuz we already got it but you
know grow with video live that's a
strong brand YouTube influence like
that's a strong name but it's our
challenge name video ranking Academy so
sometimes to Heather's point even the
back-to-basics dog training
you might be an online course you do it
might be one of the products you offer
and so as an entrepreneur we hope you're
always journaling gathering collecting
your ideas potentially your names and
and save them because you might be using
them later they might be an aspect a
private coaching group a private product
a service that you do and you will be
able to have that name see light of day
sometime okay Julie rapid-fire to keep
reminding 90s bball cards channel about
basketball cards from the 90s strong yep
what do you feel about nicknames such
their name is Brianne Ramirez I think
it's how you say it and their channel
name is Gro re well what kind of content
is it I think you know Cass Thompson
career advice Casas the nickname of
Cassandra and it's really clear what her
channels about I think again bro REE
when I think of like the biggest
entertainment vlogger Viner tick
stalkers like a lot of times their names
like kind of are meaningless except for
that they became known so bro recon dove
sounds like you know somebody who would
win a Streamy award again the challenge
is what is what are you trying to build
and what you noticed that probably if
you hang out around our community for
very long you realize we really lean on
the practical we believe that there's so
much opportunity to have success on
YouTube and honestly the hardest path
not that we would want to push you away
from it but that if you want to become
like more of a famous comedian or a
famous vlogger
that's a tough road but if you pick a
hobby you pick a niche you pick a
problem to solve that that's actually a
practical road to monetization to impact
it's having a clear audience and so I
think Heather would say something
similar but Heather your thoughts yep
that's what I was gonna say it really
depends on the content and again you
know are you just trying to be
entertainment value what does that look
like so really just leaning in and I
think overall what we talked about
tonight really has to do with the brands
that you're trying to build and really
think
about that but not overthinking it so
again it's not just gonna be the channel
name it's not gonna just be the channel
header it's gonna be the cohesive
holistic brand that you're trying to
build online and I understand that could
feel like a really big thing but that's
where we want you to be thinking we want
you to be thinking bigger but taking
action in small steps so true okay I
want to get through a couple more of
these before we have to end at the top
of the hour we have Santa Corky talking
about holiday experiences very Taylor
okay I think this one is really
interesting I full of you spelled like I
full of my they collect Eiffel Towers
I'm assuming like little tattoos yes I
would say that it sounds like a fun
channel sounds like a kind of a cool
idea but I'm gonna lean back with some
advice on this is think marketing right
and there's maybe other other YouTube
channels and whatnot that would send you
in a different direction or YouTube
teachers but we really want to help you
build a business that breaks through the
noise we want to help you build a
full-time income our mission is to help
10,000 people create a full-time living
doing what they love while making a
difference in the world with YouTube it
online video and it goes back to a few
confuse you lose and some mentors of
mine told me that when it comes to
marketing clarity is actually more
important than creativity because
sometimes if we get like it like so
that's a very creative way of spelling
Ifill it's kind of a creative way and if
you want to kind of potentially have
like a hobby channel and whatnot then
then you could be really creative and
have fun and you're like yeah it's kind
of a play on words and like okay cool
but if you're thinking about breaking
through the noise so it has to do with
your ambitions of what you'd want it to
scale to like if you confuse you lose if
you confuse with spelling if people are
unsure what if
what it is if they think it's one thing
but it's really something different when
you said eyeful I actually would until
Mel said and I collect the small Eiffel
Towers I was like it's like an eyeful
it's maybe like a romance thing I'm
getting an eyeful an eyeful of so you
just confused me right and that's all
I'm saying if you want to get
subscribers you want to get momentum if
you confuse you lose clarity is power
for building a YouTube channel that cuts
through the noise and my friends there's
a lot of noise right there is a lot of
competition out there there's people
there we're not just competing against
other youtubers we're competing against
Hulu Netflix Final Fantasy 7 remake come
on we're competing with against mobile
gaming people can spend their time in a
lot of places so we owe it to them when
we're branding our YouTube channels to
say hey this is what I'm all about this
is what you're gonna see this is why it
matters this is exactly what you can
expect you are trying to make a decision
if you want to watch this content or not
and so here's exactly what it is
creativity is amazing and creativity and
marketing is amazing but creativity
needs to be submitted to clarity not the
other way around you never want to
sacrifice clarity for creativity's sake
you want to make sure you lead with
clarity and then you wrap it in
creativity so people go man that's so
creative but I know exactly what it is
that you do okay so we're not gonna be
able to get to everybody's channels and
everyone's questions but I want to
encourage you guys we do these live
streams on a regular basis so if you are
not subscribed then I would jump on our
mailing list because you'll get
notifications every time we go live also
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications that's a surefire way to
know when we're gonna be going live and
as always be active on our social media
if you are part of the challenge get
active in the challenge group it is very
active there's a lot going on there and
it's an amazing opportunity to connect
with other people in your niche other
people doing YouTube and also get
feedback on the different things that
you're working on so definitely
definitely get active in that Facebook
group if you are not part of the
Facebook group check
your email because we want to get you in
there it is
that's where everything is going down
for the challenge if you haven't opted
into the challenge yet tube influence
comm I'll let Sean chime in on that yeah
absolutely go to tube influence comm to
be a part of it we've never done
anything like this before and I feel
like this is an opportunity that's
actually never been gifted it to us
before look I'm empathetic I know that a
lot of people are hurting right now who
were going through a lot of hard times
in the world you know just here in
America over 30 million people have
applied for unemployment benefits
industries have been disrupted we're
dealing with domestic violence on the
rise we're dealing with anxiety stress
we're dealing with financial hardship
and then globally it's affecting
everything lines of Trade and all this
different stuff look there's a lot that
we can't control and a lot happening
around us but what we can control is our
actions right now we can control
starting something building something I
know for me I started YouTube and I got
serious about YouTube during the hardest
season of my life in the recession of
2009 so when I say that I actually think
this time in history can be viewed as a
gift is when I look back we lost our
finances we lost friends when we were a
part of a church that fell apart and we
my wife's health was under attack and it
was the hardest season of our life but I
look back and I saw that I was the one
of the best seasons of our life because
of what it caused in us what it pulled
out of us the shift it we you know
sometimes in life we don't change unless
something comes and knocks us off course
and calls causes us to reevaluate
everything and we too will reap if it
recreate re innovate our strategy and
our game plan and so if you're locked
down right now you're on furlough right
now if you're working right now be a
part of this challenge because we're
gonna create some major momentum that
just like the recession of 2008 9
changed the whole course of my life and
have has us here today
like if you're seeing this you can hear
my voice that's why we're here today is
because of a crazy time in the world
that disrupted my life that caused me to
fight for something more to discover a
new level of purpose a new level of
vision
and to put in the hustle because I got
so clear about where the world was going
and guess where the world's going video
streaming online you need to establish
your influence on YouTube and we're here
to help and we want to give you a gift
of a 7-day free challenge that's gonna
help you create major momentum in your
life in your business on your YouTube
channel hope you connect with other
purpose-driven creators and
entrepreneurs and how there's going to
be a part of it Mel's going to be a part
of it and so many incredible people and
it's entirely free so if you go to tube
influence comm link in the description
below and I want to thank you so much
for checking out this video as well the
video we want you to watch next is that
video about naming your channel with a
few additional tips and software and
tools that's going to help you so click
or tap the screen to watch that video
thanks so much for being a part of this
episode of the think marketing show
click the screen to watch the next video
and we will see you during the next show